quick game of which doesn't belong and
why cowboys at 10 giants at 11 eagles at
12 which doesn't belong and why three
nfc east teams back to back to back
i say the cowboys at 10 because i can't
see
the cowboys taking a skill position
player
in this slot and i could definitely see
both the giants and the eagles doing so
i'd say the eagles at 12 because based
upon the story from the athletic a
couple of weeks ago the fact that
jeffrey lurie is an amateur
mel kuiper i don't know what the hell
they're going to do in relation to what
their board
says and i don't think they know what
they're going to do and we'll all find
out when they do it jaguars jets
dolphins teams with multiple first-round
picks
and all three have three picks in the
first 36 selections
which doesn't belong and why jaguars
jets dolphins
i'd say the dolphins because the
dolphins are the one team that's not
going to take the quarterback
um although you are spreading the
the kernels of uh of of you know sort of
quarterback seeds on the ground in front
of the dolphins i don't see it
those other teams obviously the first
two picks in the draft
are both going to be quarterbacks yeah i
may be spreading something other than
kernels on that point but just trying to
have fun with all the possibilities the
jaguars don't belong because to me
the jaguars are a team and i know trent
bauke is there as the gm but urban meyer
introduction to the nfl running his
first draft we heard him complain about
free agency
this is all new to him so who knows what
they're going to do and
they've been hiding in plain sight with
the number one overall pick all this
time
we don't talk about the jaguars nearly
as much as we should be given they've
got the first overall pick for the first
time in franchise history and they're
taking a guy who's been ordained as the
first pick in this draft
for more than two years last one which
doesn't belong and why
from tom petty i mean tom brady's
list of pet peeves being taken 199th
the royals player who had the who had
the brady jersey on and said patrick
holmes is better
or the single digit jersey expansion
which of those three
peaves from tom petty don't belong and
why and there's
there's the royals player whose name i
knew the other day because it was in
front of me i don't know who it is now i
know it's not brady
but but uh which doesn't belong and why
oh that's so that's i didn't even see
that that is hilarious
i'd say the one that doesn't belong is
the jersey expansion because
that is something that actually happened
you know that's that's a that's a that's
a uh you know a new nfl rule
the other things are just falderol
well 190 being picked 199 is not falter
all because it has motivated that guy he
has held a grudge
longer than anyone for 21 years he's
still upset and as sims pointed out
when we talked about it not that long
ago when we see that picture of him from
the combine
we know why he went 199. it's his own
fault he went 199.
and then he becomes motivated by the
fact that you know he deserved to go
199.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports